you uh spoke recently about Warner
Brothers having the rights to distribute
the Friday Series yeah and that's
obviously your intellectual property
right you came up with that movie yeah
the most impactful movie of my entire
life I was talking like Smokey yeah from
like age eight to twelve my favorite
that's my favorite movie one of my
favorites I know that entire movie by
heart like it's it's bad like I could
recite it when I watch it I watched it
so much as a kid by the way top three
soundtrack ever too oh yes dope yeah one
of the best soundtracks ever
um is would you say because you know
you're somebody who's been revolutionary
in so many ways
um is is that a like what lessons did
you learn from the Friday series and not
retaining ownership or not necessarily
being you know in charge of the the
destination of where it goes when you're
doing movies now
is that something that's front of the
mind you know like if you oh it's part
of the game you know when you do a movie
you have to get it distributed and if
you want your movie to be
um
taken you know as you know high level
entertainment
uh there's only a few
houses and Studios that can deliver that
um so at the time we didn't have you
know wasn't no streaming Netflix
internet Hulu so we had to assign the
movie to new line
to distribute it and new lines connected
with Warner Brothers so
um you know sometimes when you do one
movie with a company they have the
rights to release the sequels that's
part of the deal and that's the Clause
that we're caught in you know they have
the right to release the sequels and so
the way the stalemate is to not release
you know to do a few and stop and that's
what they did they did three and they
stopped
um and we've been asking them to get the
movie back here's why they won't get a
movie back
Ride Along Straight Out of Compton
new line had both of those movies
they told me both of those movies would
not work on a major scale
we took those movies out of Warner
Brothers took them to Universal
you know so they worked 150 million
dollars from from Ride Along 200 million
from straight out 250 from Straight
Outta Compton so we really embarrassed
embarrassed them so they was like man
you really embarrassed us on that you
know I mean like
uh so we was like man y'all y'all don't
believe in it so give us the [ __ ] back
and they like we can't give you another
movie back cause I'll get fired you know
so it was on that tip you know they
didn't want to be embarrassed so they
didn't want to let Friday yeah as a fan
I was I always just assumed Chris Tucker
was just not wanting to do it because
because after the third one it was like
okay if they do a fourth Smokey gotta
come back yeah and obviously rest in
peace to John Witherspoon yeah
um Tiny Lister Tiny Lister passenger
Johnson there's some a lot of very big
parts of that universe that have passed
yeah man and that's why I hate you
Warner Brothers because they they let
that happen we could have shot those
movies way before those guys passed away
um I'll never forgive Toby Emerick and
the guys I was running the show at the
time Faizon Love because they shot the
face
you know they let guys pass away who was
counting on this movie
yeah and that Universe like fed a lot
like dude I remember you would just go
to like the monster Dub Show and Tiny
Lister would be just there with his body
yeah taking pics like I think it was the
most his most recognizable character oh
of course one of the most recognizable
characters ever he embraced being called
Debo first what like if you say like you
know that's not his name but you I feel
like that's also like a like uh people
call you Craig yeah it's like a verb you
could be like yo I Depot
wait who called him Craig my youngest
son he came to the house and my little
my youngest son he's 28 now he's a
little boy he just Craig
[Music]
that's how young you are